why
so with Krysten Ritter having been cast
to play the role of Jessica Jones in the
Netflix series that will lead up to the
defenders miniseries I figured now would
be an excellent time to do a video about
her character now what I also want to do
is I want to give a big thank you to Sal
from TV Little House for helping me comb
through a lot of the information
involving Jessica Jones and Jessica
Jones I guess encounters with a purple
man with a zebediah killgrave because
there were some misconceptions that I
had about the relationship the two of
them shared and so what we see with
Jessica Jones is that her character is a
very important character in the realm of
Marvel Comics now what she's not so much
important because of the character that
she is because of the roles that she
plays Jessica Jones is very important in
the realm of Marvel Comics because of
how she was introduced to us Jessica
Jones was introduced to us an alias in
November of 2001 and she was a creation
of Brian Michael Bendis now at the time
Brian Michael Bendis was and what's
considered to be probably the most
popular writer that Marvel had going at
the time due to his involvement with
with ultimate spider-man as well as
daredevil and so what Marvel was looking
to do was to launch in an adult-oriented
series of comics called Marvel max and
Marvel max would be a series of comics
that we would see play out that would
include
sexual content nudity adult oriented
language and so on again these were
series of comics that were targeted
specifically for adults and so with
Brian Michael Bendis having been so
popular at Marvel Marvel had reached out
to him to provide the first series that
would be part of the Marvel max imprint
and this is when we saw the 28 issue
series called alias coming to fruition
now with alias issue number one we're
introduced to Jessica Jones as the
individual running something called
alias investigations it's a private
investigation team where I guess a group
that she's running by herself that will
allow her to track down various cases to
meet with various individuals and of
course allow her to create an income for
herself now for the most part she's
successful in this because of the
contact that she has because she has
contacts like Carol Danvers like Steve
Rogers
and these are the kind of things that
people are looking for with this Netflix
series that they're hoping we'll see
Carol Danvers being brought in we're
hoping her people are hoping we'll see
Scott Lang who she had a romantic
interest in for a while being brought
into the Netflix series but over the
course of the alias publications of
course we see her taking on various
cases and and going through various
things but her origin story isn't
actually given to us until alias issues
number 23 22 through 26 now during these
stories we of course see that she is in
an on-again off-again relationship with
Luke Cage but her relationship with Luke
Cage really seems to be more of a
relationship a sexual gratification than
anything else the two of them aren't
really romantically linked to one
another they're really just uh
fulfilling each other sexual desires
here but what we learn with alias issue
number 22 is that when jessica jones was
a child that her actual name was Jessica
Campbell and that she harbored a very
intense infatuation for Peter Parker now
she had never really been able to bring
herself to make her advancements or her
interest in Peter Parker known but she
was able to finally muster up the
courage on the same day that Peter
Parker was bitten by a radioactive
spider now because Peter Parker was
bitten by this spider his attention of
course was taken away due to the almost
immediate sudden I guess influx of the
powers that he gained which resulted in
him becoming spider-man and so Jessica
Jones is simpler I guess yeah Jessica
Jones at this time had simply chosen not
to make her advancements known towards
Peter Parker and so what she did was she
began to go about her own business to
continue living her own private life but
during this time her and her family
while they were driving are involved in
a car wreck with a vehicle that's
transporting dangerous and radioactive
chemicals across state lines and as a
result her entire family with the
exception of herself are killed in the
car wreck and so she falls into a coma
now she's able to finally come out of
this coma due to the the fact that a
Galactus and a Silver Surfer are
attacking the planet Earth and when she
comes out of this coma she's informed by
a social worker that of course her
family is dead and that she's going to
be put into a foster home with a family
called the Joneses hence the reason she
becomes Jessica Jones this is her
adopted name and so with alias issue
number 23 we pick
where she's rien rolled in Midtown high
school by the Joneses in an attempt to
make sure that she's able to maintain
this level of consistency in her life
but because of the fact that she had
fallen into a coma she's ridiculed at
the hands of Flash Thompson and other
people and simply just referred to as
coma girl now one important thing to
bear in mind is that at this point Peter
Parker has already developed his powers
he's already playing out the role of
spider-man and so Peter Parker is one of
the few individuals who tries to reach
out to her in fact he's probably the
only individual that tries to speak with
her but because of all the ridicule that
she's received up to this point she
takes his attempt at conversation to be
an attempt to make fun of her and so she
runs away now when she's running away
she begins to have flashbacks to the car
wreck with her family so the social
worker telling her she's going to be put
into a foster home and her powers of
flight manifest
now again she doesn't really know how to
control these abilities and so what we
see with her character is that she
basically lunges high into the air and
then lands in a river and when she lands
in the water she's immediately rescued
by Thor now from here she begins to
experiment with her power she begins to
experiment with what it is that she's
capable of and what she learns is that
she has some measure of super strength
when she picks up her bicycle with very
little effort and so when she puts this
to the test she's able to physically
push over a tree and so what she does
learning about these newfound abilities
as she goes out and comes across a
scenario with a scorpion an enemy of
spider-man is trying to rob a laundromat
and she's successfully able to stop the
scorpion now from here we're going to
take a detour from the alias comics and
we're going to jump to amazing
spider-man issue number 601
and during this story we of course see a
conversation taking place between
Jessica Jones and Peter Parker where she
tells Peter Parker about her life when
she was younger about how they had both
gone to the same school about how she
had had an interest in Peter Parker
Peter Parker doesn't really remember her
he tells her he doesn't really recall
her that the only thing he recollects is
that she was referred to as the coma
girl but aside from that he doesn't
really remember anything but what
Jessica Jones says is that at this time
when she was younger she had seen Peter
Parker it seemed spider-man fighting
fighting the Sandman and because of this
she had decided she wanted to be a
superhero
you wanted to model herself after this
ideology and he decided to take on the
role of being a superhero and so from
here we switched to alias issue number
25 and we picked up with Jessica Jones
as she's continuing this story with her
friend at this time Luke Cage and what
she does is she gives us some very
valuable insight in terms of what it's
like not only to be controlled by the
purple man but what her life was like
while she was controlled by the purple
man and what we learned here is that
after she had undertaken the role of
being a superhero she had adopted the
codename jewel and with the name jewel
she began to go along the process of
fighting various villains and so on but
there came a point whereby she was
investigating a disturbance at a
restaurant and there were two
individuals inside this restaurant who
were fighting one another while a man
who was completely purple dressed in a
purple suit was watching the events
unfold and this man of course we know
was zebediah killgrave and what he does
what he realizes Jessica Jones is there
is immediately take over her mind he
tells her that she's a very beautiful
woman and then using his mind control
powers tells her to undress herself now
before she's actually able to expose any
of her genitalia he tells her to stop
and to to stop the police forces outside
of the restaurant which of course have
arrived and attempt to quell the
domestic disturbance and figure out
what's going on and what Jessica Jones
begins to tell us is that from this
point and over the course of the next
eight months she was totally kept under
the control of purple man that purple
man despite the fact that he had engaged
in a multitude of various sexual
endeavors had never actually forced her
I guess forced Jessica Jones to have
sexual contact with him and this is
where my misconceptions began to come
into play and this is where Sal had
corrected a lot of this information that
I had what what's up and I kilgrave had
done or what he would do is during this
time he would go out and he would take
over the minds of a couple of female
college students and then he would take
them back to a hotel room and he would
force the female students to engage in
sexual acts with one another as well as
sexual acts with himself and then he
would force Jessica Jones to watch and
as he would force her to watch he would
force her to beg the purple man to allow
her to join in but the purple man would
never let her do it and of course when
there were not any college students for
a purple man to a kidnap he would simply
just force Jessica Jones to beg the
purple man to allow her to have sex with
him but he again would never actually
allow her to do it and as Jessica Jones
explains it to us the entire concept was
extremely unrealistic but at the same
time it seemed as though it was
something that she wanted to do and what
I mean by this is it's not as though she
had done it of her own free will the way
she explains it to Luke Cage the thought
seems to be something that comes from
her own mind despite the fact that the
purple man is forcing her to do it and
so it's an organic thought it's a
realistic thought as far as her mind
thinks and so for her she genuinely
believed it was something she really
wanted to do because it was a thought
that was put in the mind of her by
purple man now over the course of these
eight months as she explains to Luke
Cage there came a point when zebediah
killgrave had I guess told her to go
kill daredevil and the reason why is
because he was very angry at the fact
that he had never been able to figure
out who daredevil was and the daredevil
had consistently been able to thwart his
schemes in an attempt to - I guess
engaged in some kind of nefarious
activity and so what he does is he tell
her tells her to either go to the Baxter
building or go to the Avengers mansion
or wherever but to find daredevil to
kill him and to kill whatever superhero
she encounters along the way and so she
immediately takes off and what she does
is she gives us again a little more
insight into what it's like to be
controlled by the purple man what she
tells Luke Cage is that the further away
she got from the purple man the more the
his his pheromones his mind-control
began to wear off but the problem here
is that while she knew what she was
doing was wrong while she knew that she
didn't want to do it she couldn't help
but do it and so along the way she
encounters The Scarlet Witch and she
immediately attacks the Scarlet Witch
because her mind does not make the
connection between the fact that the
Scarlet Witch is not daredevil she
simply just sees the skull at which sees
the Scarlet Witch is dressed in red and
immediately attacks her and so what we
do is we see that her that once she
realizes that she's a tag the skull at
which she tries to take off she tries to
escape but of course she's pursued by
the Avenger
and from here we switched to alias issue
number 26 and with alias issue number 26
we see of course that as the Avengers
are going against her that Carol Danvers
realizes who she is now Carol Danvers
doesn't know who jessica jones is on a
personal level she simply knows who
jessica jones is in the sense that she's
a superhero and so while the vision is
pummeling jessica jones due to the fact
that jessica jones had attacked his wife
at the time Carol Danvers is able to
help Jessica Jones escape but the
problem here is that Jessica Jones due
to the fact that there's no influx of
control or pheromones from the purple
man her mind ends up shutting down she
ends up falling into a coma and once she
wakes up from this coma she of course
realizes that the various Avengers are
here and she goes into this guilt ridden
trip now during the time that she was in
this coma during the time that she was
unconscious she was visited by Jean Grey
and what Jean Grey tells her is that
she's here she's there to help Jessica
Jones get past all this to help Jessica
Jones move move beyond where she was in
terms of the psychological trauma that
she had endured at the hands of the
purple man now what we also see here is
Galactus walking around inside the mind
of Jessica Jones now we don't exactly
know why Galactus is here it may very
well be that this is simply a a
recollection of Jessica Jones when she
had woken up from her first coma when
Galactus was attacking the planet Earth
but most likely this is due to a a
psychic defense that that Jean Grey has
put in place something that we will see
manifest itself later on and the end the
purple event but once Jean Grey is able
to help Jessica Jones get past the
Stockholm Syndrome she was suffering for
and her belief that purple man genuinely
loved her Jessica Jones again wakes up
out of her coma and so Jessica Jones
begins to go through the psychological
and physical therapies that are involved
in helping her get past this entire
conflict now over time after an
unspecified amount of time we eventually
learned that she's revisited by the
Avengers and the Avengers tell her they
apologize for attacking her in such a
way they apologize for for simply just
hobbling her more or less they had
recently come off of a high-stress
mission and so what they
is that if she's interested there's a
place for her on the Avengers team if
she chooses to join but Jessica Jones
says no she says that she felt as though
nobody cared that she was gone during
the eight months
nobody had realized that she was gone
that her mother had felt as though she
had simply just stopped talking to her
that no one had been concerned of the
fact that she had simply just vanished
and so what she does is she takes this
time to leave and she ultimately forms
alias investigations so with the final
issues of alias issues number 26 27 and
28 what we had seen is that Jessica
Jones and Luke Cage began a formal
relationship with one another due to the
fact that Jessica Jones had become
pregnant because of the sexual I guess
relationship that her and Luke Cage had
but what we saw with alias is that with
issue number 28 this series came to a
close in January of 2004 now what Marvel
was looking to do was to find a way to
capitalize on the overwhelming success
of Jessica Jones in the alias series but
the issue that they had was that due to
the fact that the story was part of
Marvel max they weren't able to actually
fold the character over into any of the
main storylines or any of the main
Avengers teams without bringing her into
the the mainstream Marvel comics and so
what they had to do is they had to
remove her character for Marvel Max and
introduce her into the main Marvel
Marvel mainstream comics and so what
they did is in June of 2004 Brian
Michael Bendis launched a series called
pulse but the problem here is that pulse
only lasted for about 14 issues running
until 2006 and pulse was considered very
lackluster in comparison to alias and
this was an idea that was
I guess maybe coming from the concept of
looking at Jessica Jones and having her
play out the role of a writer for The
Daily Bugle who was writing a column
called the pulse which was really more
of an attempt of j jonah Jameson to use
the newspaper as a means to smear
superheroes which was the reason why
Jessica Jones ended up leaving the pulse
in the in the end and of course it
became a background care
from that point going forward and this
is what we see with her character after
the events of alias and after the events
of polls Jessica Jones very rarely ever
becomes a character who steps into the
limelight she does to a degree she read
the arms her costume for a short time is
nitrous but for the most part she is a
character who is relegated to the
background during Civil War for example
she's only in the comic for a short
period of time when Tony Stark
and Carol Danvers travelled to visit her
and Luke Cage and an attempt to bring
them to the side of Tony Stark and this
was of course something we had talked
about in our Civil War videos but what
we had seen with Jessica Jones is that
she and the daughter of herself and Luke
Cage Danielle had traveled to Canada in
an effort to stay away from everything
that was going on with the superhuman
Registration Act in the United States
while Luke Cage stayed behind to fight
on the side of Captain America and again
over the course of her comics this is
how we see her portrayed she actually
doesn't get a solo colleague of her own
anymore after the events of pulse she
simply just appears in various events
and stories she of course it was I guess
a relatively a large part of the Secret
Invasion event but more so after the
events of Secret Invasion than the
Secret Invasion event proper and so
again we see her character simply
falling away from the limelight we see
this element of her that made her very
unique in terms of her introduction and
the stories that made her interesting
and aeleus begin to give way to her fit
simply just kind of falling behind now
from here the really interesting concept
here the really interesting discussion
is the question of what is Marvel going
to do with her character when she
actually gets her own Netflix series is
Marvel going to adapt her character to
play the same kind of role she had
played in the pulse or are we going to
see this alias type of character with
Jessica Jones and if we do see this
alias character is Krysten Ritter the
kind of actress who is going to play out
the very dark and the very gritty roles
that we had seen that Jessica Jones
playing in the alias comics are we going
to see a situation whereby she's forced
into a position of a subservience at the
hands of a person who can control Minds
it's purple man even going to be a part
of the Netflix
these are questions that a lot of people
have and at this point it's really too
early to know for sure I would go as far
as to say the Marvel's probably still
fleshing out a lot of the pots and still
trying to figure out what they're going
to do with regards to her character with
that being said we're going to go ahead
and bring this video to an end I hope
you guys enjoyed it if you didn't let me
know and I will catch you guys later
peace